Hello，大家好，我是Zou Yi。
大家好，我是Lin Lu。欢迎来到逛街专家。
这一期我们聊义乌。义乌呢，表面上是一个巨大的小商品市场。
但它真正让人震撼的是你会第一次如此具体的看见，价格从哪里来？
品牌一家有多高？制造能力怎样变成了消费冲动？
义乌不是一个简单的买便宜货的地方。
它对我们来说好像更像一堂线下商业课。
7月初的时候我和朋友去义乌旅行了一趟。
在义乌逛街的过程中，我感觉自己就像被打了麻药一样。
整个人都是晕晕呼呼的，而且还会不断地发出那种哇嗚的声音。
义乌到底有什么样的魅力？
作为一个超级爱消费爱买东西的人，
我在这个有一万种小商品的城市发生了一些什么奇妙的感受。
今天我要来和我的搭档云露好好聊一下。
我今天刚刚收到你给我记得义乌占了一瓶的快递，
我也发出了同样的声音。
在真正去义乌触摸到在义乌卖的商品之前，
我依然存有小时候对小商品的刻板印象就是质量不好但便宜。
但是现在是好且便宜。
这是最终就是我的一个总结性发言吧。
我们从头开始聊你是为什么想去义乌啊。
因为太好奇了呀，现在有很多的博主或者是有很多去过的朋友，
似乎就是一个零差评的旅行目的地。
再加上他离上海又非常的近过去很方便。
这个地方他也不是什么旅游忘记，很适合夏天去那里待两三天。
我是玩了整整两天嘛，早上去晚上回然后住了一个晚上去了两天。
那你在义乌花了多少钱你统计过吗？
没有。
但是其实我觉得他不会是很夸张的数字，我可以大致讲一下我的行程。
第一天我基本上就没有买东西，就是吃东西。
因为义乌的餐厅非常的多，
然后义乌也有很多的咖啡馆和甜品面包。
第一天我们就主打这个部分，
去到韩国街吃各种小吃咖啡面包，面包非常好吃。
这是第一天，然后也把义乌本地的奶茶都尝了一遍。
第二天主打购物，
就从早上酒店出门直接逛到晚上坐火车走，这样的一个两天。
你跟你的朋友在义乌算是那种散户吗？
你们是有专门去那种散客零售的专门的区域，
还是说会跟那些批发商混在一起？
我们是做过攻略的，我们去的就是纯粹对散客非常友好，
允许你只买一个，然后那些产品也非常的，
就是非常的新，非常的新潮，是当下最流行的小商品。
我在义乌遇到好多跟我一样，就是来旅行，
吃吃喝喝，顺便想买点东西回去的人。
然后我们还聊聊天，大家站在那个櫃台那里游泳浴，
一开始还有点不敢买的那种状态。
然后都是店主主动破冰吗？
用多种语言问你想要点什么？
完全没有。
义乌所有的店主都不需要跟我们任何人破冰，
因为义乌的商品就是最好的宣传。
他东西摆在那里，价格也在那里，
只有需要就是询问他说这个比如还有没有别的颜色啊，
这个杯子是不是还有还有除了样品以外的新的款式啊，
就除了这种问题以外，他其实完全不需要宣传，
而且他们也会把自己的二维码都贴在店门口，
你离开之后想再买也可以。
反而是我和其他就是铜逛店的人在那聊天。
比如说有一个很漂亮的小姐姐，
她就想买一个大品牌的包，某知名运动品牌的包。
她跟我聊了好久，
她男朋友也给她做了很久的心理建设。
她的点就是说她怕别人笑她，
然后我就亲身告诉我说这个包，
我给她看了我的淘宝记录，
我说你现在时候拿着这个和我在添猫店买的分不出区别，
然后她的价格差大概在一个1-2折左右，
10-20%的价格。
我说我真的到心破碎，
然后她最终还是没有买，
这个很有意思，
就是她真的好想买，
她男朋友也说无所谓嘛，
对吧，她质量非常好，
然后我也向她证明了我作为一个买过正品两个的人，
这个是分不出来的，
她也还是没有买。
我觉得女生还是对这个事情是，
心理上是很卖不过去这个看的。
她的道德水平还是比较高的，
也很尊重品牌，
对，当然我觉得确实她会在意说，
那我背这个，
如果其实是她人的目光，
如果看到了我背的不是正品会怎么样，
那我一直跟她说我说看不出来，
真看不出来。
还有一些是另一种真爱粉，
就是某个IP的支持者，
因为一物就是满坑满骨，
都是各种各样的当下最流行的IP的周边，
我就在微信群里和朋友们聊天，
然后他们确实很喜欢这个IP，
也为她曾经花过很多钱，
但是看到我给他们拍下的，
在这里的价格的时候，
就倒心破碎，
对，然后但是也有人安慰自己说，
不可能的，
我买的那个正版质量没有这么好，
真的有一个男生他就这么说的，
我看这个脸太正了，
他说我买的那个正版有点歪的，
没有这么好。
哎，但是这样卖不会担心，
会有法务找上门来吗？
哎，这就是我这一切很想聊的一个问题，
因为我自己，
确实在一开始逛的头三家店，
我都没有买，
就是那个道德杰皮，
或者是法律问题，
提醒着我，
前面的时候都还处在一个谨慎和保守，
没有放开自己的状态里，
但是呢，
就是你确实亲眼看到那些质量是很好的，
而价格也是一个低到了，
超过我的想象的价格，
我的理智就一点一点的在丧失，
我看过非常多，
与这个事情相关的脱口秀，
一个段子是说，
我用真钱买的鞋，
为什么要说它是假鞋？
真钱买的就是真鞋，
所以我觉得购买这个非正版品牌，
商品的这件事情中的道德和法律问题，
我们作为消费者是不是不要扛下这么大的包袱，
而是品牌方或者生产商，
销售方他们应该解决的问题，
确实我本人在义务买了非常多非正版的东西，
而且非常的快乐，
因为我只是消费者，
这件事情的道德和法律的压力，
应该给到生产销售和品牌方，
免责声明说完，
然后我再说下一个，
也是在买的过程中的一个思考，
因为我买了很多送人，
就是那些小的小钥匙扣，
包括我买了蛮多送人的，
这个过程中有一个朋友就聊到，
其实如果像，
就你现在这样，
你在逛义屋，
你看到这个是我喜欢的IP，
你问我要不要一个，
你送给我，
我当然要，
我是很开心的，
但是他说我换了一个思路去思考，
如果是，
像我们公司经常有圣诞礼物交换，
或者是我过生日的时候，
你拿一个房品送给我，
我应该就没有办法像今天这样高兴起来，
这个问题是在于，
你是把它当成什么东西来送的，
你现在去送人，
其实相当于是一个你一屋旅行的伴手礼，
分享给你朋友你的这种旅行的建文，
而如果你在这种更慎重一些的场合，
像交换礼物的这样场合，
或者如果生日这样场合，
你没有说这是一屋来的，
那朋友收到你的心意，
会默认他是一个有更多品牌一家的心意。
对，就我朋友也说，
他说,
即使你告诉我，
我也会割灯一下，
就是为什么你会在圣诞礼物交换，
或者我生日的时候，
送一个房品给我，
尽管你可能是诚实的，
你没有试图用房品，
假装正品送给我，
因为如果用房品假装正品，
那是个更严重的事情，
那是欺骗了，
但是就是同样的仪式感，
和我这种顺手直播，
买给你的小心意，
他确实还是不一样的。
好，好，好，
我们其实把这一期里面，
我们最可能聊起来，
最困难的一个部分，
先放在前面聊了，
因为所谓的有IP风险，
或者说品牌方面的东西，
其实只是一屋，
这种上意的小商品当中，
很小的一部分，
在这里面，
你可以看到各种各样的，
不同的，
你想不到的品类的那种小东西，
大东西，
对，我们也看到了，
非常多昂贵的东西，
不是小商品啊，
有大概两笔高的那种，
奢华的那个中表，
然后还有灯式，
家具,
奢侈的地毯，
但那些都不卖给我们这些散户，
那很多都是走外貌的，
他很多都是走独立站，
或者是走阿里巴巴，
或者是走亚马逊出去的，
对对对，
那些甚至就是不卖给国内，
但是他有豪华的展体，
真的是会被那些灯式，
尤其是还有地毯给吸引住，
因为真的好漂亮，
但他不卖给我们，
所以我们就看个过瘾，
我逛前，
我是心里好像隐隐约约有一根线，
就是我知道我想买什么，
以及有什么东西，
我大概是不会在义屋买的，
所以我去搜了一下那个，
义屋小商品市场，
他们官方网站上，
对他们就是经营范围的一个定义，
就包括了日用百货，
视频，玩具，工艺品，
礼品,
文体用品，
真知，仿知，
小家店，
小五金，
化妆品，
香包,
鞋帽,
拉链,
扭扣,
节日用品，
汽车用品，
总之他的特色就是四个字，
小,
多,
连,
快，连就是那个连架的连，
就是体积小，
品种多，
价格低，
更新速度非常快的消费品，
但是我逛的时候，
我有看到我很喜欢的。
品牌的款式的保温杯，
我完全没有动心要去买，
就是因为我那一刻有一个。
警钟想起，
就是他还是跟安全有关，
然后他是进嘴的，
他是直接接触我身体的，
我可能还要
更谨慎一点的购买，
所以我没有买，
在这个维度上面，
品牌一架又变成了一种。
对于品质的，
品质标准的背书，
就是这个安全保障，
这个背书，
还是挺重要的，
你比如说我买，
我买了很多发甲，
这个东西，
他不会有任何的安全风险，
我不需要任何一个品牌，
为他去定义他的安全，
所以我就可以放心大胆的买，
但是保温杯我，
这个,
他同样是个小商品，
我就没有买，
我可能会更倾向于，
去官方的正品的店里，
万一他有什么问题呢，
我是承受不了那个风险的，
然后我带着这些东西回家以后，
我也分不清了，
这是目前的现状，
其实今天在和你录播课之前，
我还试图把我那个。
木头盒子里头的，
四个发甲，
摆出来看看，
到底哪两个是，
我在天毛店买的，
哪两个是我在义务买的，
同一品牌的，
价格是，
十倍的差异，
余倍,
就是一个是，
我算一下，
一个是198，
一个是20倍发甲，
是10倍,
是10倍吧，
我没算错，
包括我买的，
抓甲,
我带到了店里面去，
就是我夹在头上，
带到店里去取下来，
和店里面的正品比，
我也没有分清楚，
这感觉跟我平常，
网购的习惯也差不多，
比如说我在某书上面，
刷到那种，
推送种草的，
刷到短视频种草的，
什么抓甲，
发甲,
什么收纳用品，
我上过几次档以后，
我就会把那个图结下来，
去1688去搜关键词，
基本上那个价格，
也是10倍，
你在短视频里面，
刷到的时候，
那个价格可能是19.9，
你觉得其实已经很便宜了，
但是你一搜1688，
那批发价式，
可能是3.6，
甚至是1.6，
甚至还可以一键代发，
就刷到的时候，
就觉得自己，
很冲动，很想买，
但是你去搜1688以后，
可能会觉得，
这个价格没有那么合适，
同时我也不想买了，
我夏天喜欢带的，
所有的小耳环，
几乎都是这么买的，
就是通过美丽的，
漂亮的图片种草，
以图搜图买下那个，
因为这个东西，
它可能真的带几次，
我也不会喜欢了，
我就用一个非常低的价格买，
我想分享就是，
在义屋那一个，
就是医区东阔的，
专门接待散客那个区域里，
有几个品牌，
低价格高质量的，
也是我这次重点买的，
就是Mount Bell,。
Lululemon,Taki,。
还有那个Wasaki那个IP，
以及所有的，
Powermart新西人的IP，
新西人是一框一框，
在卖10块钱，
它肯定是有这种，
法律的风险在里面，
但就像你说的，
我觉得它，
这个压力不应该完全，
由消费者来承担，
是生产，
销售以及品牌，
尤其是品牌方，
应该要去承担的，
如果你把这个房品，
送给了朋友，
朋友感受到那种压力，
或者割灯一下，
其实也是这一个，
传导压力链的一部分，
但是1688,
我们刚刚说的那种情况，
又不一样，
1688其实是在，
在他们这个，
Tubi的电商体系里面，
是有很明确的，
面向,
小红书，
面向拼多多，
去宣传，
这种,
选品的便利性，
就是想要帮那些，
小微商家，
赚到钱，
当然,
我们这种，
会看到19块9的链接，
去搜1块9的渠道，
但是对于工厂来说，
他们还是希望能够，
找到这种，
带货的达人，
或者说小微商家，
或者说开店的人，
把他们一个，
1块9的销量，
变成100个，
1000个,
甚至上万的这种，
带货的销量，
那这个中间的差价，
或者说这个利润空间，
是要留给中间商的？
对,
我其实也认同中间商，
它有存在的价值，
就像中间商，
它至少是会帮我们选品，
它至少是会，
让我们看到，
这些东西是怎么应用的，
它的真实的使用场景，
和那些图片的呈现，
这个事情是有价值的，
但是,
所以我前面讲说，
我在义屋的时候，
整个人像被打麻药一样，
我们也是跟做品牌的人，
深度接触的，
我们也深刻的知道，
做一个品牌出来，
它是有大量的成本的，
对,
我的小时候，
我妈是给我买过，
假的阿迪达斯的裤子，
但是因为我本人，
既不认识真阿迪达斯，
也不认识假的，
我就直接穿了，
然后在学校里，
被同学狠狠嘲笑，
甚至他们，
刚开始嘲笑我的时候，
我还不知道为什么，
直到后来有好心人，
像我解释了你那个，
就是那五个字母之间的线，
还是连在一起的，
真的阿迪达斯，
他那个缝线，
就是五个字母是单独的，
这样子，
所以我，
因为这个阴影，
导致我自己其实还，
你可以说是虚荣，
也可以是争一口气，
我是一个满支持正版的，
我是能用的软件，
我尽量的买正版，
能支持付费的，
尽量用正版，
衣服,
鞋子包包，
我为品牌一价，
付出了我这，
几十年工作的努力，
我都花在品牌一价上了，
就允许，
我就允许自己在义屋，
就当放纵一样，
用非常低的价格，
去买到这些购物的快乐，
这就是我当时，
回到家里以后的一个，
总结。
就有一个朋友，
他是每年会去，
两趟义屋，
然后他有一个小小的裙，
会在裙里面直播，
他在,
当地看到东西，
但他主公的品类，
一个是珍珠，
视频,
还有一个是水晶，
还有竹台，
香薰这种东西，
然后他这里后，
才发现会有，
那么多的款，
不仅仅是我们在，
在那些，
几个我们所谓看到的那种，
新消费，
新国货品牌里面看到的款，
就是,
义屋这个生产，
制造,
设计能力，
好像是，
完全没有瓶颈，
对,
多是,
我,
没有办法用语言，
形容的，
就是,
义屋到底有多大，
东西有多丰富，
这个事情，
真的是我语言，
匮法,
我没有办法，
我只感觉，
他朝我铺面而来，
他一栋楼，
就有好多好多层，
每一层，
可能有，
上千个店铺，
而他有，
几十栋楼，
所以你可以想象到，
那个,
产品的丰富程度，
你说的那些珍珠的，
视频,
水晶的配饰，
或者是那些，
小珠珠串串的，
单独的零件，
我也看到了，
但是那个太密了，
就是我做一个，
个人消费者，
我在那里，
挑不出东西来，
因为那个，
那个,
我面临的选择，
太大了，
如果我是去进货，
比如说，
我要做，
一千条，
手链的，
视频的配件，
那我可能能去挑，
但如果我只是，
想要自己，
做一些，
几条手链，
去挑那些珠子，
挑那些，
零配件，
我是无能为力的，
站在那种，
巨大面前，
丰富程度，
本身就会，
给你打一张麻药，
你就被，
垫到了，
我还想讲一下，
就是,
义乌,
当然不是，
一粗而旧，
成为今天的义乌的，
义乌的，
崛起,
跟中国入市的，
这个红利，
是,
分不开的，
两千年之前，
义乌市场，
在改革开放之后，
那二十年里面，
成为了，
内贸的龙头，
那随着，
全球化的加速，
和中国入市，
越来越多的，
境外客商，
到义乌采购，
市场的，
内外贸结构，
就开始了，
历史性的反转，
死后就，
逐年的爬身，
你看,
你在那个，
东阔那边，
看到的那种，
不像散户，
甚至不像，
国内销售那种，
明显面向，
外贸的展厅，
为什么，
大家去义乌，
会去,
韩国街，
会去吃，
去探听，
也是因为，
有非常多的，
外籍商人，
在义乌常驻经商，
从而才，
形成了这么一个，
非常,
小,
但是又非常，
国际化的一个，
城市面貌，
其实一开始，
义乌是，
只做销售的，
但是后来，
他,
渐渐的链条，
升到了，
更后端，
就是开始，
从设计，
生产,
开始把握，
整个,
就是,
全球,
对小商品的，
成为了一种，
全球小商品的，
气候所在，
它不再是一个，
纯粹的销售，
对内,
对外出口的，
一个窗口，
我觉得，
是不是可以，
这么理解，
你有没有看过，
川普拉达的，
魔头里面，
那个,
他们的，
真的对话，
就是说，
全世界，
每年流行的，
服装款式，
颜色,
高跟鞋的样式，
就是由这几个，
最重要的人，
在这个办公室里面，
决定的，
有这样一段，
对话的台词，
一屋,
某种意义上，
也是这样的，
角色,
它的工艺的进步，
它的,
生产链条的，
不断的进步，
它的超级工厂，
它的设计能力的，
突飞猛进，
它的质量突飞猛进，
它把握了，
全球小商品市场的，
气候,
它不是来料加工，
它不是流行什么，
造什么，
某种意义上，
一屋已经在，
更前面了，
是一屋造什么，
世界流行什么了，
对它是，
当然也跟，
这种,
包括像TikTok，
像Timo,
Shopee,
阿里巴巴，
亚马逊，
这样,
这些平坛的努力，
是分不开，
但是,
一屋这么一个，
特别的角色，
放在这里，
你说的很对，
就是,
一屋造什么，
世界就流行什么，
虽然我们经常，
看,
短视频的时候，
会,
开玩笑，
说,
下面压力，
给到一屋，
就看到一个东西，
那我们说，
压力给到一屋，
但其实可能，
那个东西，
只是我们，
我们还没有通过，
我们的渠道，
拿到我们的手里，
对,
我一直在想，
就是,
一屋,
拼多多，
阿里巴巴，
他们某种意义上，
都是,
量很大，
东西很便宜的，
这样子的，
销售平台，
线上线下的，
但是我觉得，
他们还是，
很不一样的，
就是,
阿里巴巴，
它像是一个，
面向全世界的，
属于全中国的一屋，
因为它不只卖，
我们所知道的，
浙江这个，
义物的商品，
它还有很多的，
广东的，
然后山东的，
广州的服装，
然后其他地方的，
家房,
这些东西，
统统都会汇聚到，
阿里巴巴，
然后被全球的，
商家,
就是,
采购过去，
影响到全世界的范围，
但是,
义物呢，
它是一个，
更线下，
更聚焦的，
品类的，
批发商，
当然现在，
而拼多多说实话，
它,
杂柔了很多的淘宝，
和很多的义物，
和很多阿里巴巴的基因，
但是拼多多，
它又有很多，
让我,
始终无法原谅它的地方，
比如说，
它有大量的，
广告文，
文案,
和图片上的，
欺骗性质，
比如你买一包纸，
看着很便宜，
收到之后，
发现它这支架盖那么大，
然后它卖大量的，
盗版的书籍，
这些都是，
我觉得拼多多，
可能没有义物，
和阿里巴巴那么，
让我更喜爱，
更接受的原因，
同时,
拼多多，
它就跟一无不同的地方是，
它还是只在做销售，
它压榨了两头的利润，
压榨了生产方，
压榨了农民，
把那边的，
商家利益，
压到足够的低，
然后同时，
在,
在这边又给你的质量，
也压到了最低，
它其实做的是，
一个纯粹的中间商，
但义物和阿里巴巴，
做的事情，
它有联通，
它有生产制造，
然后它还有这种，
打破交易的，
瓶颈和门槛的，
这样一些功能，
所以我觉得这三者，
看似有相似的地方，
但是又不太一样，
而且,
我的建议是不要拉踩，
但是我跟，
拼多多去看过，
不少产业代的，
他们的建设的努力，
所以我感觉，
本质上他们，
发挥的作用，
其实都是联通，
买卖两头，
联通产地，
和有需求的人，
这另一段，
有需求的另一段，
是批发商也好，
还是一个一个，
具体的消费者也好，
不管他们联通的，
卖的这一头，
是工厂也好，
还是说，
田间地头，
直接收过过来的农民也好，
就是这个过程当中，
我们,
包括我们上一期，
提到,
为什么要付钱，
给超市去做选品，
就中间商的存在，
它中规是有意义的，
只是,
中间商，
如何用，
何种形式，
去组织商品，
组织商品的流通，
如何让人看到，
让需求方，
看到这些供给，
这个是不同的平台的，
运营各自的，
运行的策略，
都不一样，
本质上，
他们没有太大的区别，
但是我们能够，
从我们的，
实际的消费体验，
看到,
他们各自的气质，
这差距太大了，
包括1688,
他们,
我之前有看他们的，
内部的，
呃,
选品的演讲，
他们的所谓，
之前叫，
拿货节，
或者商人节，
他们也有，
完全面向，
拼多多的铺货呀，
去看,
阿里巴巴的那个界面，
看他那个，
一件采购，
一件代发，
上面就是秘密麻麻的，
可以发小红书，
可以发拼多多，
这也可以铺到淘宝，
有赞,
就是,
这些基础设施，
做得都非常的完善，
但是话说回来，
还是非常的佩服，
这些,
坚持在，
最源头那些工厂，
他们,
日复一日，
源源不断的，
这种,
设计和创新。
每一年开始，
阿里巴巴，
变成了，
C端的,
爱买东西的人的，
一个秘密，
他现在，
其实,
已经是公开的秘密了，
但是,
我英语，
记得最开始的时候，
大家还是口味相传的说，
其实,
淘宝上的东西，
阿里巴巴能买到，
一模一样，
而且便宜，
对不对？
好像是最近几年吧，
因为阿里巴巴最开始他的，
他甚至都没有，
移动端的网站呀，
有时候我在阿里巴巴上，
看到一件衣服，
觉得挺好的，
等我下单的时候，
他告诉我，
要买1500件，
他是面相批发的，
面相散户的，
而且,
也不是所有东西，
你都可以领买，
有些服装店，
他就像那种线下，
男牛的那种，
线下展厅一样，
你只有跟他，
非常的熟，
以后,
建立联系后，
他才发款给你，
让你选嘛，
你不可以，
就是那样，
一件一件领买，
他也不像，
在其他的，
2C的购物平台一样，
你可以七天五里由退化。
对,
他确实，
但是,
阿里巴巴，
他这样开通了，
一部分的，
允许个人购买的，
功能有了，
不然,
让我们下单，
跟方便以后，
你觉得，
对淘宝有冲击吗？
是,
总归是在哪里，
这个货盘，
就是中国的，
这种制造能力，
和设计能力，
已经是，
非常的强大了，
最难的地方，
其实,
都是各个平台，
在努力的地方，
这是,
如何让消费者，
发现,
他有这个需求，
以及,
让你下单，
去买,
生产出这个商品，
把这个商品，
挂出来，
其实不难，
是引流，
对吧,
你看,
为什么，
抖音电商，
坏手电商，
小红书电商，
花了那么大力气，
去宣传，
他们的重槽能力，
是因为，
那些东西，
你要把它卖出去，
卖上价，
这个就是，
个品本事的，
嗯,对,
所以,
始终还是，
流量是最贵的，
能把,
能把消费者的，
注意力，
消费者的，
下单决策，
吸引到，
我所在的，
平台上来，
货之间的差异，
可能,
没有那么大了，
甚至有可能，
就是我说的是，
非常接近的东西，
只是大家，
各出奇招，
来把消费者的，
购买,
这个预算，
拉到我这里来，
对吧,
你去一屋，
你也说了，
你感觉像，
被打了马药一样，
那也是一种，
线下购物的氛围，
就是你被那种，
巨大量的，
零狼满目的商品，
所冲击，
现在那样一种，
氛围里面，
虽然你回来以后，
以及在当时，
都有反复的，
受到这种，
道德和法律风险的，
这种自我的边斥，
但是,
你还是晕晕，
乎乎的就买了呀，
就是在那样的氛围里面，
一个人，
很难管住罪的钱包，
这也是一种，
销售的手段，
对,
哎呦,
我现在，
有一点，
醒过来的感觉，
是,
当时,
其实我确实，
保持过理智，
半小时吧，
就是前三家店，
没有下单，
到后面就，
完全失去控制，
其实,
我们家里面，
都有批发市场，
对不对，
合肥有批发市场吗？
诶,
陈黄妙，
卖什么，
去买笔心，
开学的时候，
去买文具嘛，
然后买袜子，
批,
批家里面的，
各种袜子，
还有,
什么,
小五金箭，
塑料盆，
这种,
就是你明显的知道，
你去那里，
可能会有，
质量,
层次不起的风险，
但是呢，
它确实价格，
跟文具店里面，
包括超市里面的价格，
相差非常的多，
那,
在北京的话，
其实,
我之前有跟，
呃,
朋友来北京的时候，
会介绍他们去逛，
百容世貌嘛，
我就会介绍说，
这是我们，
封台区的小义屋，
里面也是，
一个批发市场，
什么都有，
我有的时候，
比如说，
小孩的学校要求，
某种风格的，
节日配式，
那我就会去那里，
有几家，
专门买，
节日配式的店，
尤其是杨杰，
就会有，
不同风格的，
节日配式，
在那里卖，
我就会去那边去挑，
对,我,
其实在义屋，
有看到，
前两年，
我们家也还，
认真过万圣节的时候，
我有,
购买,
相当昂贵的一些，
万圣节的视频，
现在他们，
还在,
储物间里，
撥挥,
但,
在义屋，
确实看到了，
同款的，
万圣节的视频，
价格也就是，
三分之一不到吧，
大概,
四分之一，
五分之一的样子，
我,
我确实，
因为节日的消费，
它是,
也是,
有点像礼物一样，
是一个很特殊的，
比如说，
大家在圣诞节的时候，
会在家里，
布置圣诞书，
或者过年的时候，
会有一些，
专门,
春节的布置，
但这些东西，
只能用那么一会儿，
它不是一个，
你需要长期，
消耗的东西，
可能这也是，
义屋,
把节日用品，
当做,
它一个重要的，
品类的原因，
确实你说到的，
这种特殊日子，
专属的东西，
就是以便宜，
能用,
为标准，
来购买就好了，
而且,
我就,
很多年前，
我们去，
我去采访，
亚马逊中国，
他们去分享，
加在亚马逊，
销售的，
非常好的品类，
当时,
我们不太理解，
为什么说，
家居原意，
是一个，
名列钱毛，
还有汽车配件，
在亚马逊上，
销售的非常好，
后来去了美国，
看了他们的超市，
就是,
即使,
义屋的老板，
已经,
转了十倍了，
但是,
放到他们的超市里面，
还是一个，
非常非常便宜的价格，
我妈是个，
非常喜欢购物的人，
然后呢，
在我们长沙，
是有,
比试炼的，
逢年过节，
要买好的衣服，
我们要去广州买，
所以,
长沙开通了，
专门去广州的那种，
我称它为，
购物大巴，
就是,
都是女性，
大家坐着大巴，
去广州买，
过年穿的好衣服，
诸州货，
是要被嘲笑的，
因为诸州货，
在,
在当地人眼里，
就是相对，
质量较差，
较为便宜的，
然后,
长沙有两个大的，
批发市场，
一个是食品类的，
叫高桥市场，
小商品类的，
就像义乌一样，
叫夏合街，
夏合街现在已经倒闭了，
而且夏合街以前，
因为它也是那种，
满坑满骨的小商品，
就像你说的，
买文具啊，
买一些小的，
日用品的地方，
所以,
我对夏合街的，
记忆就是，
被偷过很多次，
在那种批发市场里，
被偷钱包，
和手机是，
非常非常寻常的事情，
高桥市场呢，
它又不一样一点，
像我们平常，
比如说，
买个巧克力，
买个大白头奶糖，
它是有一点贵的，
但是,
如果你是去那个，
批发市场买，
或者是旺旺雪饼，
它是一个，
透明塑料的包装的，
它也是正品，
但它的价格，
就比你在超市，
拿一个旺旺大礼包，
要便宜很多，
可能是一个五折左右，
所以,
每一年，
我们半年货的时候，
我家有个亲戚，
在高桥，
做生意，
就是通过这个亲戚，
大批量的采购，
海鲜干货，
还有那个糖果，
我人生中，
最早最早吃到的巧克力，
大白头奶糖，
还有咖啡糖，
全部都是来自那个，
批发市场，
它就一次，
比如说，
巧克力得买五斤，
很夸张，
大白头奶糖得买十斤，
一个大，
大包装的，
这种,
它没有拆小的包装，
它是没有办法，
用于送礼，
也没有小包装，
它只能用于你在家里，
款待客人，
我们对于，
价格在不同，
一个同一个东西，
不同的渠道购买，
会有不同的价格，
这个认识，
可能就来自于，
这种,
每个城市的批发市场，
对,
我们之前，
聊选题的时候，
我说过，
我是要回长沙，
去逛一次，
我们长沙，
还存在的，
诸州服装批发市场，
而且我在小虹书上，
也看到，
真的,
诸州服装批发市场，
它已经幻发出了，
全新的生命力，
它是一个，
拥有不同风格的大楼，
每一栋大楼都有自己，
专门的特长，
适合批发的，
适合忙买的，
以及那种，
最潮流，
质量最好，
不讲价的，
不能试穿的，
各种风格的商场，
已经发展出来了，
是有新的生命的，
诸州批发市场，
这个,
会是我们，
未来的一期选题，
服装批发，
和小商品批发，
可能还不太一样一点，
嗯,
这个是不是就像，
杭州的四季亲，
像深圳，
广州的那些，
什么,
南游市场一样，
上下九，
对,
应该是每一个城市，
也有自己，
专门的，
服装的，
批发市场，
和小商品，
和食品，
这些不同的，
品类的，
批发市场，
他们覆盖的，
范围可能也不太一样，
我就以前去采，
大欧门，
还有动物园的，
批发市场，
很多都是，
跟北京有，
直通大巴的地方，
他们过来，
拿货,
嗯,
诸州就好像是，
现在年轻人的，
因为我所知道的都是，
嗯,
九九年，
零零年的人，
他们会在，
假期专门，
一起去诸州，
买一批衣服，
诶,
但是这个，
可能会以，
夏装为主，
因为,
漂亮的，
凉鞋,
漂亮的裙子，
你可能对他的那个，
面料,
质感要求，
没有那么高，
诶,
那是不是应该现在去啊，
现在差不多，
应该是，
夏装要清货的时间了，
马上要上秋装了嘛，
对,
我,我,
赶紧安排上去，
逛逛诸州，
好,
替我们去逛一逛，
打一打，
那么即使，
你不去，
买东西，
也有很多，
值得去，
逛的地方，
你的钱，
不仅可以花在，
小商品市场，
也可以花在，
这个城市的，
一些其他地方，
你有什么推荐吗？
我很推荐你去，
因为你写人物故事，
我可能，
比较外向，
我很爱跟人聊天，
我真的，
只是随随便便，
和网约车，
司机多聊了一句，
就听到了，
非常丰富的故事，
他首先，
一开始，
也不是炫耀吧，
就是分享，
说他有两个女儿，
说他的两个女儿，
在义屋当地，
非常好的国际学校读书，
他的两个女儿，
的学费分别是多少，
当时我和朋友就很震惊，
哇,
网约车司机，
要供两个孩子，
上这么贵的学校，
这个太不容易了吧，
我们一路开过去，
还是说，
我们住的地方，
叫义屋之心，
他说,
在我们住的地方，
市中心，
附近有几个小区，
非常贵的，
他在那边买了一套，
很贵的房子，
那个房价，
大概好像要七八万，
还是,
就是一个很，
很离谱的，
让我们都，
都惊讶的一个价格，
他在那边买的房子，
他住在那里，
这个时候，
我们已经对这个司机的财富，
产生了，
迷思,
怎么会这么有钱，
然后这个时候，
他后来才告诉我们，
就说,
啊,
我说,
您就是开网约车，
挣这么多钱吗？
他说，没有，
我每年只开半年网约车，
他说,
主营的业务是做手套，
是那个，
特别防寒的那种，
羊毛的，
真皮的那种手套，
然后专门卖俄罗斯，
所以他在不做手套，
不卖手套的，
像这个，
烟热的夏天，
他没有事情做，
他就开网约车，
还有是那种，
早年间，
我是一个，
我是一个公司CEO，
但我有点无聊，
反正在家，
也显着，
也是显着，
出来开开车，
聊聊天嘛，
他纯粹显着，
就是因为时间很长嘛，
他不卖手套的，
他不是一天显几个小时，
他是一年会显半年这样子，
所以他就是做半年的网约车司机，
然后卖半年的手套出口，
俄罗斯，
然后买下了他，
给我们介绍了那个豪宅，
然后把两个女儿
供到了，
私立国际学校去读书，
我觉得这个司机，
而且他是江西人哦，
他不是本地人，
他是他的整个，
家属都到了义屋，
一个带着一个的做生意，
到了义屋，
然后成为了他们这样一个，
应该是大型的，
手套雇营商的，
这样一个家族企业。
对，有一点，
我们也之前没有提到，
就是像批发市场，
就这样的地方，
像义屋这样的地方，
或者说像工厂这样的地方，
他们的生意，
都是有明显的季节性，
而且也跟实际的季节，
是有错位的，
比如说现在可能，
已经是圣诞节商品，
外圣节商品的，
这个忘记的一个尾声，
在义屋应该对于，
整个经营贸易，
制造,
或者是外贸的，
跨境电商的这些，
采访对象来说，
那应该是一个宝藏，
所以你应该可以去义屋，
找到一些，
你都不用刻意去约，
你就打车，吃饭，
对吧，在那里买买东西，
认识到的人，
都是非常非常有故事的人，
不用说义屋的美食，
我自己吃到的东北菜，
韩国寿司，中东菜，
还有甜品，还有面包，
至少是85分90分以上的水准，
就是,
所谓义屋是世界美食之都，
而且我们甚至没有，
专门去挑什么，
特别热门的馆子，
就是在那里随手吃到的，
吃到的东西都非常的好，
我觉得因为义屋，
它居然流动非常大，
所以能长期开下来的，
大概率都是符合，
这个世界美食之都的要求的，
然后同样，
哪怕你就是不买东西，
去见见世面这件事情，
也挺重要的，
我回来之后，
和我老公的表妹聊天嘛，
他们本来是，
订了西湖边的酒店说，
想带孩子，
领略一下江南水箱的风景的，
听我讲完，
我去义屋旅行的故事之后，
他们全家就决定去义屋了，
从德国回来的一家人，
对,
因为他们，
知道在德国这些东西有多贵，
上一次回来的时候也是暑假，
他就提前大概，
我觉得他至少买了30个快递，
寄到我们家里，
然后当他到上海，
因为他第一站到上海嘛，
他就从我们家把这些快递拿走，
我说你到底买了什么呀，
这么多个箱子，
你猜是什么？
全是文具，
因为他有两个小孩，
上学,
他们的文具实在是太贵了，
就是一整盒整盒，
可能30个50个那笔这种，
我想想我给在国外的朋友，
转运过什么东西呀，
什么切菜器啦，
什么收纳盒啦，
然后什么反正，
我们平常在那种，
TikTok上面,。
在抖音上面会刷到那些，
生活当中，
又有点花巧，
又无用的小玩意儿，
我通通都给朋友转运过，
对，宣指，
对，自贴，
因为他要教小孩写毛笔字，
毛笔,
还有普通学习用的中心笔圆珠笔，
就是这些东西，没了，
全部是，
这一次他们就是，
要带小孩去买小玩具，
孩子喜欢的，
因为这些东西，
确实在欧洲，
价格可能就不是10倍了，
甚至他还在开玩笑说，
让他女儿尝试，
在他读的中学里面，
要不要卖给他的欧洲同学，
只义务尽一点货，
这是非常非常吸引的，
我其实没有想到，
我把我在义务旅行的经历，
就是吃饭的时候分享出来之后，
能对别人就是，
会有这么大的吸引力，
首先这个丰富程度，
然后这个价格，
以及我给他们看了我买的东西，
他们非常震惊于这个质量，
没有想到会是，
这么好的手感和这么好的症，
你也收到了，你看到了对吧，
没有任何让你觉得，
我这是一个很廉价的，
很不精致的东西，
他完全没有这样的，
他有点过于精致了，
他完全超越了我的想象，
虽然我已经看到过图片了，
我确实也很期待，
找个时间去义务，
再去亲身逛一逛这个街，
对，你真的可以去义务，
做做选题，
我推荐所有的记者朋友，
做消费的记者朋友，
去义务看一看，
那里的人，
他们真的是在第一线，
他们在生产制造，
销售和全世界联通的，
第一线那些人，
就像那个网络车司机，
对他的手套是自己造，
自己卖，
就是他们以整个家族的江西人，
他不是纯卖，
你义务是一个我想做的选题，
还有一个选题就是华强北，
义务是偏这种小商品，
华强北就是更偏
3C数码类的义务，
就是什么东西，
他可能都有一套
非常通用的解决方案，
可能一个品牌他卖的东西，
可能还在众仇的
华强北已经造出来了，
我觉得你看到更多的东西，
你了解这个定价，
了解这些质量，
了解他的品类，
反正他其实不是互斥的，
并不是说我逛过义务之后，
从此我不再支持品牌，
我不再网购，
我也不再相信正版，
我还是会被那些品牌。
故事打动，
我还是会为我喜欢的IP，
去付出那些义价，
反正我觉得了解这些是。
没有坏处的，
他是一个非常美妙的。
逛街的体验，
然后你懒得逛的街，
我们都可以去帮你逛，
感谢收听本期的逛街专家，
这期我们带大家
云逛了一下义屋，
容易分享了他去逛义屋的。
感觉，对他来说，
就像逛了一个
个人的迪士尼一样，
如果你还有什么，
想让我们替你去逛一逛的街，
也欢迎你留在评论区告诉我们，
对，事实上我已经逛了，
下一期就聊我最近逛的街，
好，看到看出来我们的分工了吧，
有一个人负责在前方逛街，
有一个人坐在网上逛街，
好，那今天就到这里，
拜拜,